okay so you need to do a bit of language
right so for instance in question one
they say fractional form to have a look
see these two here right that's a
fraction so this side here is fractional
form okay and this is not this is with a
negative index so it's one or the other
so in 1a when they say write each in
fractional form
okay they want us to go from the left
hand side right over to the right hand
side shake you see that so what's gonna
happen here I'm gonna I see the negative
index right so I'm gonna say 1 over and
then I'm gonna change the sign right so
now it's positive 1 but of course 4 ^
just one is just for take a that's it
okay now you can see in 2a they asked
you to go in the opposite direction okay
so you've got the fifth now it's a bit
tricky just like I was mentioning this
to Darcy before if I showed you a number
like say 7 is that positive or negative
it's positive but how do you know
there's no sign out the front okay
there's no sign you assume it's a plus
right now in exactly the same way when
you don't see any index you assume it's
a 1 okay cuz 5 times itself once is just
fine so now that I have an index there
right I can go backwards i I'm in this
case over here
I've got 1 over 5 to the 1 so I'm gonna
cross the line now I'm on the numerator
and I'm going to change the sign they go
that's it there's the fraction form
there's the negative index form okay now
moving down a three here's what you've
got
okay now just like before this is um
more number two we know what to do in
this I don't know what X is but doesn't
matter I know that it's the same base in
both cases okay so when you divide
numbers with the same base what you do
ya you subtract the indices now watch
out subtraction
just do subtraction in any order you
like right four minus three is not the
same as 3 minus 4 so this order here in
matters right so that's why the 3 and
the 4 in that order
3 - 4 of course is negative 1 so now I
think the question says simplify each of
the following using only positive
indices now that's another way of saying
put it into fractional form because you
see that's that's not a positive index
is it right so that's going to be 1 over
and it's just X that's it that's the
simplified form ok um now when you move
into question 4 & 5 they're really doing
the same thing as 1 & 2 I think yeah ok
so for example for a right they give you
this 5 ^ -2 can you see it's just like
this right it's a number negative index
okay so I'm going to do the same thing
to it it's gonna be 1 over right I've
crossed the line so I should change the
sign it'll be 5 but they don't keep that
- there okay I haven't got rid of the 2
I've just changed it so okay so that's 1
over 25 I think they say yeah I mean we
want to get rid of those would be the
same thing the same number okay when you
go 5 it's just like this we're going in
the opposite direction right so you've
got 1 over 7 squared that's 1 over 49 so
I'm going to cross the line now the
numerator so I should change the sign
from positive 2 it'll be negative -
there you go
Negi